Yeah. So the guy was just a little all over the place. Um, his,
his tour wasn't that tight, you know, we went on so many tours.
I started to like really rate the tour guide. Yeah. I put the tours together,
by the way, because I get a congrat or like a good job or something.
You're just so good at it. Yeah.
You're so good at planning how we're going to see the kids.
Thing. And y'all know, she mentioned this too,
when we were sitting in mine plots on the last day, you know,
we had a flight to catch in about an hour and a half.
But you think the German company,
the German government was alerted to us being there because they were like,
why are these two guys bopping around?
You're going to every single tour this city has to offer, who are these kids?
We just kept going on tours.
Yeah. You know, I, you know, me having my German roots and as being Greek kid,
you know, Yanis just wants to like look at sculptures and you know,
he's just looking around, taking his time.
He's always late for things and I'm just more anal with it. Cause the chairman.
So like I kind of,
after being four or five days and being almost late for everything the last day
I kind of, and Yanis mentioned this, I kind of was like, you know what?
Maybe I just want to,
maybe I just want to see what happens when I turn the temperature a blessing.
Maybe I just want a fry. That's what happened? That's it? Yeah. Let me,
let me just, let me just.
See if I can just put some panko and breadcrumb on him.
Let me just throw him in the office. Yeah. That's it. You see, we figured,
we figured out what's behind the German personality of the 1930s and
forties that led to Nazi-ism and fascism by our relations because yeah,
I was a little late. Chris is really organized with the tour.
Like we saw when we would go to sleep, we were sleeping. Basically.
We were sleeping in a hostel with these farmers. We slept.
He literally had to, I'm a grown man with a family.
Yonis is 43 years old about to get married and we've slept in twin beds.
Two twin beds.
We did have a phone charge for the whole trip. I know. Well, I got.
That. You got to do dig. Get. Gave me the one for England.
Anyway. So Chris is just always the one like, okay. Cast that saw to sleep at,
uh, 1300 hours,
Toby app at 7:15 AM because of how to go to the talk
FARs that forced the haircuts to York. When he was a young child,
you and Nick with dogs to wake up,
then he wakes up and he sounded the alarm will go on. And I'm a Greek kid.
We'll go ahead. Hey, listen, come on.
Having a cup of coffee drink is hanging out. We're just taking our time here,
baby. We'll relax. We're ready. Lux, philosophical, paperboard.
And he's going well, come on. I see.
So the battle.
Between this went on for days until about the T the fourth day,
Chris just kind of was running out of patience and that's when he slowly,
it's just, that's how Nazis it. They just kind of like pick your efficiency,
gets challenged and you just, by the fourth day,
you're just going ice and it just comes out.
Yeah, because Yannis kept. Yeah. He, for some reason,
ganas just kept the wrong way.
Even though the cars come the same way as the U S I don't even think you notice
it. You just kept thinking we're in England, you were looking the wrong way.
And we were crossing the street once walking back to the hotel. And I said,
let him just look the other way. And I wouldn't tell him a Cod's coming.
You were going to push me, weren't you.
I was just going to give a little push and then say, I don't know.
So that would happen. I just,
I hate that you walked into this Tufin strife and street.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about,
this is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate and review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boards,
where things get really wild.